e
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález aunque el
nombre que recibe la alianza militar
firmada entre eeuu el reino unido y
australia corresponde a un ambicioso
pacto de seguridad de alto nivel en el
que estos tres países van a compartir
avanzada tecnología de defensa que busca
contrarrestar dicen ellos los avances de
china en la región del indo pacífico el
punto de este acuerdo que más resonancia
ha tenido es el hecho que australia va a
ensamblar y a recibir también submarinos
de propulsión nuclear australia ha sido
enfática en que no va a recibir armas
nucleares más detalles se los cuento en
el siguiente informe
estoy realmente enojado y lo que me
preocupa es el comportamiento de los
estadounidenses para que se decidió
venir a llegar esta brutal unilateral e
impredecible decisión se parece mucho a
lo que trump haría escribiendo youtube
esta fue la primera reacción de francia
ante el llamado acuerdo auto con el que
eeuu y reino unido le proporcionarán a
australia la tecnología necesaria para
desplegar submarinos de propulsión
nuclear la molestia de parís es porque
al ser excluido del pacto se queda sin
el acuerdo de 65.000 millones de dólares
que tenía con australia para reemplazar
los submarinos collins que el país tenía
en oceanía el primer ministro boris
johnson intentó calmar los años
whitford siguen meses pixies nuestra
relación militar con francia una vez más
señor presidente es sólida como una roca
y estamos hombro a hombro con los
franceses ya sea en el sahel donde
estamos ejecutando una operación
conjunta contra terroristas y en
variedad agua
en estragos y estamos en estonia donde
estamos actualmente tenemos la operación
más grande de la otan anders a operation
por su parte la comisión europea dijo
que el bloque de los 27 países no fue
informado de la iniciativa a pesar de
que la unión europea lanzó este jueves
una estrategia para fortalecer su
presencia naval en el indo pacífico y es
que comparte la preocupación sobre cómo
china tiene cada vez más poder en la
región
beijing rechazó el acuerdo august
afirmando que amenaza la estabilidad y
la paz en el lindo pacífico y que la
nueva alianza afecta a los esfuerzos
para la no proliferación de armas
nucleares
ya previamente francia y australia
estaban colaborando en un acuerdo
vinculante desde el año 2016 y esto
incluía un pedido de una serie de
submarinos clase attack eran dos en
total y este acuerdo era por cerca de
36.000 millones de dólares ahora ha
quedado completamente cancelado esta
crisis diplomática entre eeuu y francia
ya ha sido calificada como la peor en
las últimas dos décadas
el elíseo ordenó el retiro de sus
embajadores en eeuu en australia aunque
ya anunciaron que van a regresar a sus
respectivas delegaciones por su parte el
presidente francés emmanuel mccomb y su
homólogo de eeuu joe biden se van a
reunir a finales del mes de octubre en
la ciudad de roma en el marco de la
reunión del g20 un mes después se van a
reunir en la ciudad de glasgow en
escocia en el marco de la cumbre del
copo 26 el regreso de eeuu a la escena
internacional ha sido entonces
verdaderamente el regreso de ese aliado
estratégico que estaban esperando los
países de la comunidad internacional
países como alemania o francia o la
misma unión europea si se va a poder
sanar esa ruptura en la en relaciones
entre parís y washington la alianza
aunque el pacto de la discordia es en
nuestro tema de debate hoy aquí en
france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a jorge heine él es
profesor de relaciones internacionales
en la universidad de boston también fue
embajador de la república de chile ante
el gobierno de la república popular
china se conecta a esta conversación
desde la ciudad de boston en
massachusetts en eeuu también está con
nosotros of law gone sardineles analista
internacional también es profesor de
ciencias políticas y sociales en el
liceo francés de la ciudad de santiago
en chile se conecta desde la capital
chilena a esta conversación y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 está con nosotros
tatiana gelves rubio ella es presidenta
del nodo colombia de la asociación
latinoamericana de estudios de asia y
áfrica también es profesora
universitaria latina gracias por estar
con nosotros bienvenida acá al programa
al debate en france 24 y comienzo con
usted aquí en el estudio preguntándole
por qué francia se pudo haber quedado
por fuera de estas negociaciones cuáles
pudieron haber sido las razones
gracias santiago por la invitación
bueno hay múltiples razones por las
cuales francia se queda por fuera
creería que la principal es el tipo de
tecnología que le ofrecía al acuerdo con
australia dado que la proporción como tú
lo decías da mucho más alcance en
términos de lo que puede cubrir en el
área de
alcance mientras que los submarinos
franceses tenían que salir a la
superficie para poder abastecerse en
este caso de diésel básicamente podría
ser por tecnología yo aprovecho antes de
darle paso a nuestros dos siguientes
invitados que también los televidentes
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síguenos como france24 guión bajo e s y
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas pasó entonces a preguntarle a
jorge en la ciudad de boston en esta
misma pregunta para a partir de su
respuesta para comenzar el debate porque
francia se pudo haber quedado por fuera
si ya llevaba adelantada una gran
negociación con australia es aliado
cercano de eeuu y pues especial preside
mantiene una cordial relación en londres
parís
sí yo creo que esto tiene que ver con el
tipo de submarinos que australia
requería no solo ya estaban avanzadas
las negociaciones con francia australia
ya había pagado 2.400 millones de
dólares lo que nos da una idea de lo
avanzado que estaba el proyecto pero aún
no se había terminado de concretar y yo
creo que acá lo que tenemos tener
presente es que esto representa un salto
cualitativo en lo que está ocurriendo en
el asia-pacífico no sólo es un tema
algunos submarinos más o menos hasta
ahora había fueron seis países que
tenían submarinos a propulsión nuclear
con esto obtiene se incorpora a ese club
muy exclusivo por una parte y por otra
tenemos que darnos cuenta que estos
submarinos aunque se señala que no
tendrán
armas atómicas van a tener la capacidad
para desplegar cohetes ojivas nucleares
de manera que yo creo que un tema muy
serio
como usted lo decía jorge incluso lo
comentábamos con tatiana fuera de
cámaras que ya entonces australia
entraría en ese exclusivo grupo de
países a nivel internacional que tiene
acceso a componentes precisamente para
poder tener combustible nuclear para
poner en marcha estos submarinos ya pasa
a estar en un club o un poco más
exclusivo si se compara con otros países
de la región y flote en la ciudad de
santiago en chile le hago la misma
pregunta para comenzar esta ronda como
porque francia se habría quedado por
fuera de este
convenio y le extiendo un poco más le
pregunto también si estamos hablando
mucho se ha dicho de un nuevo escenario
de guerra fría si estamos verdaderamente
construyendo un escenario de guerra fría
esta vez en el pacífico
primero que todo la pregunta es que
refleja la decisión de australia
en realidad francia no tiene mucho que
ver en la decisión de australia
reflejar fue la declaración rápida de la
relación entre china y eeuu y bueno
indirectamente en una relación entre
china y australia
hay una rivalidad de poder que se está
acelerando y definitivamente por razones
militares como dije en los otros
invitados que nos tratan cierto yo voy a
dejar en un poco francia la base
esto es su marina será de última
generación aunque son diesel tiene un
alcance bien bien bien potente incluso
uno tenido tiene que olvidar que aunque
sea diesel en algunas circunstancias
pueden ser más silencioso que los
submarinos nucleares porque los húmedos
nucleares tienen un sistema de
refrigeración
de lo que puede ser a veces
lo que quiero decir es que físicamente
australia también
finalmente la rechaza la oferta de
francia de alguna manera de ser un socio
finalmente prefiere buscar lo que hizo a
lo largo de su historia esa es una
tradición diplomática de australia de
buscar un hermano grande un protector
australia
psicológicamente y prácticamente siempre
busca un protector fue hay niño antes es
eeuu siempre con esta mentalidad de ser
asediada por alguna manera por los
japoneses en su momento y ahora por
china entonces es un tema más profundo
más quedará sin fría es un tema que
replantea para ustedes aquí si quiere
hacer su verano
aparecen australia y se defiende dirigía
su seguridad con la en lugar de su
soberanía y eso es un otro tema también
que tiene que ver con el final de tu
pregunta pues finalmente qué significa
ser aliados hoy en día en el escenario
diplomático internacional de hoy esto
tuvo un tema importante lo vamos a
desarrollar en el transcurso de este
programa flor en paso a preguntarle a
tatiana tatiana aquí ltm australia en la
región es el país más grande en oceanía
tiene una buena relación con todos los
territorios insulares que hay alrededor
de ellos a qué le teme australia porque
china en particular porque han tenido se
tire y afloje de relaciones cambiar a
beijing en los últimos años bueno es
importante remontarse un poco a lo que
ha pasado en los últimos diez años en el
mar del sur de china y es si bien la
política de obama tenía una idea general
de lo que era el pacífico y se hablaba
de la era del pacífico hillary clinton
secretaria estado hablaba de ello luego
hay un silencio de casi 10 años por
parte de eeuu frente a lo que significó
su rol en la región y luego viene esta
era byd en que de alguna manera
rápidamente se despliega las dos visitas
que tiene la casa blanca de líderes de
jefes de estados es japón y corea del
sur esto ya muestra que hay una apuesta
o que hay una señal de que eeuu vuelve
al pacífico y australia de alguna manera
que no ha definido su identidad como un
país del pacífico sino que discurre
entre su pasado colonial y lo que es hoy
en día como que está ahí en una tensión
fuerte sin embargo no puede desconocer
que se subió al tren chino en su
crecimiento económico que ha recibido
una gran cantidad de recursos en su pib
gracias a la educación
universitaria que ha impartido a muchos
ciudadanos chinos por mucho tiempo
entonces creo que allí hay un tire y
afloje pero también habría que
preguntarse qué punto australia puede
renunciar o entrar en una situación de
más tensión con china cuando
económicamente tiene está esta relación
tan estrecha muy estrecha son muchos los
intereses de ambos lados tanto de
beijing como de camberra jorge en la
ciudad de boston usted conoce en detalle
china por haber estado allí como
diplomático china verdaderamente se
siente intimidado por lo que está
pasando en el pacífico por esta posición
de australia por las decisiones de eeuu
por lo que pueda pasar en las aguas del
mar del del pacífico y que
verdaderamente le teme a lo que está
sucediendo allí o qué interés puede
tener con australia no
chinas noreste me australia acá lo que
tenemos una gran
paradoja que la siguiente australia
durante hasta hace un par de años fue el
país que vivió sin recesión económica
sin un retroceso económica por más largo
tiempo en el mundo desde comienzos de
los 90 hasta hace un par años atrás
ostra yen no conoció lo que es recesión
porque no por la relación privilegiada
que tuvo con china comerciando otras del
turismo a través de estudiantes atrás de
todo tipo de mecanismos de inclusión año
2015 australes tenemos un tratado de
libre comercio con china que le permitió
acceso privilegiado al mercado chino y
que australia es un país que dependía
tremendamente tiene sigue dependiendo
hasta el día de hoy pero se produjo
hasta hace un año un año y medio atrás
un punto de inflexión cuando australia
llamó a una investigación internacional
acerca de cómo se había originado y de
dónde provenía el virus o 1019
y esto al tomaron la iniciativa cayó muy
mal cayó como bomba en beijing y a
partir de ahí seguía produciendo un
deterioro de la situación de la relación
bilateral con sanciones por parte de
china con todo tipo de tarifas que hacer
impuestos y desde entonces la relación
entre ambos países ha ido cuesta abajo
en la rodada y esto que ha ocurrido
ahora con el output me parece que es la
culminación de este proceso de deterioro
en la relación entre australia y china
ahora para pasar diez años hasta que se
entreguen los primeros submarinos y hay
que tener claro que este es un proceso
que iba a tomar mucho tiempo y que puede
pasar cualquier cosa en esos diez años y
puede haber muchos cambios de gobierno y
pueden cambiar las direcciones hacia
donde se enrutan esos países los guantes
en la ciudad de santiago quiero
desarrollar la idea que usted tocaba en
la respuesta anterior sobre los aliados
y la nueva diplomacia a nivel
internacional cómo entender
el desarrollo de este acuerdo entre
estos tres países esa forma de eeuu de
relacionarse con los otros países de la
comunidad internacional cuando vemos que
países como por ejemplo china
precisamente ya ha enseñado otro tipo de
diplomacia que va más allá de lo bélico
de lo militar del acompañamiento en esas
tensiones que hay por ejemplo en korea o
que hay ahorita pues con australia y
china como entender entonces el
direccionamiento de la alianza en este
momento
finalmente francia vuelva para descansar
un poco francia es lo que tenía su
estrategia en go pacífico y pensaba que
austria estaba acorde con su estrategia
que era buscar la paz mantener la paz en
esta región
claramente por todas razones que se han
explicado antes
eeuu se prepara de alguna manera no
enfrentamiento con con china y entonces
vuelve a recrear finalmente alianzas
tradicionales entre anglosajón es por
eso que aparece un poco como se dice en
francia como pasadas pasada pasajero
clandestino y el reino unido pero en
esta
voluntad de recrear alianzas entre
anglosajones pone de un lado actores
esenciales en esta región como es
francia no hay que olvidar que francia
es un país que tiene un millón 600 mil
habitantes ciudadanos en esta región
pacífico que tiene 7.000 militares que
tiene aunque esa chica pero una flota
permanente
en esta región y también en otros países
europeos tienen algunos intereses y
algunas posiciones en esta zona entonces
la pregunta es que por qué eeuu decide
poner de lado a francia y de paso a la
unión europea
en una solución global para mantener la
paz en esta región es la pregunta que se
hace en francia en la unión europea y
que genera mucho mucho enojo
incomprensión y a veces ira entre los
europeos si jorge la ciudad de boston
acabó la ronda a la inversa que reacción
podemos esperar de china ya han
calificado allí el acuerdo como
extremadamente irresponsable la firma de
este pacto entre estos tres países pero
de acuerdo a la forma en que reacciona
china en estos casos diplomáticamente
que podemos esperar si hasta ahora el
consenso es que china únicamente ha
manifestado su desacuerdo con esto pero
que en general la reacción china ha sido
bastante cautelosa ha sido bastante
cuidadosa obviamente tenemos que estar a
la espera de qué es lo que va a ocurrir
ahora en relación a eso yo quisiera
decir lo siguiente a mí lo que me
preocupa es que tenemos acá una escala
en que la situación que existe hoy día
en el asia-pacífico en qué sentido
por una parte china ha estado
expandiendo su presencia
añadiendo mini bases navales e mini
pistas de aterrizaje en el mar del sur
de china y esto ha generado muchas
tensiones ha generado moleste en los
países vecinos en los países que
comparten el mar de china y vietnam
filipinas otros por una parte y por otra
parte eeuu
también tiene una actitud muy crítica de
esto ha enviado barcos que han pasado
por el mar del sur de china y ha ido
escalando la retórica acá tenemos me
parece una situación muy complicada y yo
creo que lo que está pasando en
australia añade una situación aún más
más grave salió un artículo publicado en
the australian un diario que sufrió en
australia llamando incluso aún a
promover un golpe de estado en china
entonces yo creo que la situación
realmente se ha puesto muy seria yo creo
que importante bajar un poco la
temperatura bajar un poco la presión
estas cosas estaban como empiezan pero
no se sabe cómo terminan cuando están en
juego potencia tan grandes como china
con eeuu puede pasar cualquier cosa
además que tengamos en cuenta que en el
mar meridional de china pasa un alto
porcentaje del comercio internacional
que parte precisamente de los puertos
chinos hacia el resto del mundo es un
punto estratégico de navegación a nivel
internacional y esto involucra a muchos
países en la región involucra a las dos
coreas japón que es un estrecho aliado
de eeuu tatiana también taiwán que ya he
dicho sentirse amenazado por esta
política esta de china de mejorar su
arsenal militar de la construcción de
estas islas artificiales en el mar
meridional y también india no ha sido
indiferente también ha empezado a mirar
con un poco de perspicacia este este
tratado que pueden decir entonces los
vecinos cómo pueden reaccionar tomar
posiciones tratar de bajar un poco las
aguas allí en el pacífico
mire santiago ahí como muchos elementos
no lo primero es que de alguna manera
algunos países tendrán que tomar
posición y como dice este proverbio afic
africano cuando dos elefantes pelean la
hierba es la que sufre entonces en el
caso de los países del sudeste asiático
por ejemplo hay diferentes posturas hay
posturas de indonesia y de malasia por
ejemplo que dicen que les preocupa que
haya una escalada de carrera nuevamente
está en la región un poco en la línea de
lo que se viene hablando en autos hay
preocupaciones hay otros gobiernos como
filipinas que se mantienen al margen
y allí pues es importante recordar que
la rf la asean regional fórum ya lleva
más de 27 años intentando generar
pacificación del sudeste asiático y está
esta nueva iniciativa lo que hace es
generar incertidumbre frente a esa
pacificación
allí se verían varios escenarios está el
quad y allí estas conversaciones entre
by denny y narendra modi pues generan
incertidumbre de cómo va a ser esta
posición de india pero también está una
esperanza hay una posibilidad que muchos
analistas asiáticos dicen no y es el
posicionamiento y el papel que juega la
sean en la región como ese factor de
esperanza y de sostenibilidad de la
armonía entonces allí puede ser que sea
en cualquiera de estos dos escenarios
pero es incierto sí completamente
incierto lo que pueda suceder en esta
región flojo ante en la ciudad de
santiago analicemos la posición que
puede tener parís y los escenarios que
puede tener francia después de haber
llegado a este punto de quiebre
digámoslo así de relaciones con eeuu y
también pues que se distancia un poco de
australia después de haber cancelado
este este contrato que escenarios tiene
francia entonces quién puede ser su
nuevo aliado es momento de mirar un poco
más hacia la unión europea mirar al
reino unido que ya está fuera del bloque
comunitario que hacer que puede hacer
parís
bueno parece hace poco ayer macrón
detuvo una conversación telefónica con
byd en standby dénia macrón france
insiste en eso y bueno no no presentó
disculpas pero reconoció de alguna
manera un error por lo menos en la
manera de cómo se anunció esta esta
nueva de alianzas de august y se han se
han comprometido que váyanse al
comprometido en instaurar el diálogo con
francia y de paso con la unión europea y
acordaron de juntarse en octubre para
tratar de hablar y proponer propuestas
concretas que podría finalmente ilustrar
una restauración de la alianza en esta
región veremos los resultados porque por
ahora bailen con europa mucha palabra
puñalada por la espalda entonces en ese
sentido en francia lo que está muy muy
cautos a francia por lo menos logró dos
cosas logró que la unión europea
se pronunció oficialmente a su favor
dijo que la actuación de eeuu y de paso
de australia era inaceptable
por lo que hay derecho cuando con
francia luego todo existen otros se
invita le dijo existen otro otra
instancia en la región indo pacífico en
la cual francia puede actuar y piensa
actual por ejemplo hace poco francia
incorporó el foro diálogo de shangri la
también
puede acercarse al cual entonces existen
otras instancias en la cual en francia
pueden hacer escuchar su voz y defender
su estrategia de estabilidad de
multilateralismo insistiendo en el
respecto de la soberanía de cada país de
la región y esperando entonces que en
los próximos meses francia y la unión
europea porque frank se insiste en que
finalmente lo que está así es también de
alguna manera ayudar a la unión europea
a tener esta famosa autonomía
estratégica que tanto le falta a la
unión para tratar de volver a tener un
peso en esta región
jorge le preguntó por los movimientos
diplomáticos que ha dado eeuu
recientemente leyendo análisis y
artículos sobre este tema uno ve una
cantidad de críticas hacia el presidente
joe biden muchos dicen sigue manteniendo
la misma línea de donald trump sólo que
ya éste no tiene presencia en twitter
pero básicamente eeuu sigue alejado de
china que fue el gran rompimiento
durante la era trump el gran
distanciamiento se puede entender la
política exterior de eeuu con este tipo
de actos hacia dónde se está enrutando
como lo vio usted si yo creo que
efectivamente así es en materia de
política exterior el presidente iba a ir
de la tenía gran continuidad con lo que
fue la política del presidente camps hay
muchos más elementos de continuidad que
des continuidad en política interna la
situación es muy distinta y ha habido
todo tipo de proyectos de ley algunos
con sido aprobado otro que estará en el
congreso por aprobarse de que manifiesta
un enfoque completamente diferente por
parte del gobierno demócrata pero en
materia de política exterior sino sólo
examinamos lo que ha sido la política
hacia china
lo que ha sido una política hacia el
diálogo estratégico cuadril lateral que
se reunirá mañana por vez primera en una
cumbre presencial en washington con el
presidente y byler de anfitrión y
medidas como las que recién se han
tomado con el alcohol todas reflejan una
línea de mucha continuidad con lo que
llevó a cabo actualmente presidente tras
esto es algo obviamente que preocupa
mucho a aquellos que esperaban una
política progresista que esperar una
política distinta yo lo que yo sí veo y
no sólo tenemos el caso de autos hace un
par de semanas atrás tuvimos también la
caída de kabul y la salida de eeuu de
afganistán que también se realizó en
forma inconsulta con los países de la
otan con los países de la unión europea
yo creo que esto refuerza lo que he
dicho anteriormente que en este momento
la opción de autonomía estratégica para
francia algo que ha planteado el
presidente matrona y también lo ha
planteado el comisionado asuntos
exteriores pero no europeo josep borrell
yo creo que adquiere mucho más fuerza
porque el mensaje es muy
eeuu está siguiendo su propio camino el
sábado está reemplazando a la otan como
la alianza privilegiada yo creo que
europa tiene que va a tener que tomar
ciertas decisiones de decisiones
importantes tatiana lo decía jorge
autonomía eeuu está tomando sus
decisiones es el momento que europa
empiece a tomar sus decisiones no
dependa de sus aliados como lo ha venido
haciendo y esto entonces en qué posición
deja una alianza tan importante como la
otan que es fundamental en la relación
entre europa y eeuu yo creo que en
general estamos experimentando toda una
serie de rupturas en lo que conocemos
del multilateralismo es decir estamos
viendo casi que una reconfiguración
multilateral en ese en el escenario
global y en ese sentido seguramente
muchas acciones de la otan hay otro
actor que no hemos conversado aquí que
es rusia y rusia está un poco esperando
y mirando las acciones que se están
dando
china también tú preguntabas antes
acerca de de la posición o la postura y
las acciones que se deben de china china
está esperando cómo evoluciona el tema
en la unión europea cómo evoluciona el
tema en la otan y específicamente de
allí va a actuar de una forma o de la
otra no perdamos de vista que china
también está en su apuesta de la franja
y la ruta así que esto implica que es
que tenga diplomáticamente ser muy
estratégico en la forma en la que aborda
y algún tipo de vendetta o de una
posición un poco más hacia la fuerza
acción mal tomada puede llegar a romper
ese gran proyecto en el cual el sueño
chino xi jinping se ha dado en la
apuesta entonces creo que estos dos
actores china y rúsia en el escenario de
seguridad por ejemplo están esperando
mucho que pasa con la otan en una
reconfiguración mundial del mundo
multilateral además que rusia también
tiene costas en el pacífico también
tiene intereses en la región y comercia
abundantemente con países que están aquí
con china con japón con filipinas
incluso pues con otros territorios más
pequeños en el pacifico tiene muchos
intereses y también vale la pena
mencionarlo llegamos a la parte final
del programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que pueda suceder
aquí pues no tenemos bola de cristal
siempre lo digo en el programa no
podemos saber qué va a pasar pero que lo
que ustedes quieren que pueda suceder en
esta relación entre washington y
washington y parís se va a enmendar esta
ruptura ya el secretario de estado-
anthony blinken dijo que ya sabía que la
relación washington parís iba a tomar
tiempo y trabajo restablecerla comenzó
con el flujo muy puntual por favor
bueno francia y extensiones van a seguir
aliados tienen muchos objetivos común en
particular la lucha
contra el terrorismo en el sahel en
stara y francia cuenta con el apoyo es
sigue contando con el apoyo de asumidos
para
realizar sus tareas militares
y esto no va a cambiar incluso bailén
prometió que van a reforzar la
cooperación entre ambos países lo que sí
es que la unión europea va a tener que
nuevamente hacer escuchar su voz hacer
que definir una postura clara al
respecto no solamente a eeuu sino que
más bien su postura frente a china y ahí
hay tensiones en el bloque la unión
europea en particular va a ser muy
interesante ver quién va a salir elegido
de las elecciones alemanas de este fin
de semana porque alemania en sí en
términos de crear esta autonomía
estratégica de europa para que europa
pueda tener una postura clara entre
china y eeuu
se necesita que alemania tenga una
postura clara a favor de la autònoma
estratégica plano y terminó con eso
alemania alemania es un gran socio
económico de china y hasta ahora man
mantuvo un cierto silencio frente a esta
problemática china y entonces estos son
un desafíos a corto plazo y mediano
plazo para france la unión europea
porque para usted que viene en los
próximos meses en este tema sí yo creo
que el dato clave que hay que tener
presente es que hemos visto un traslado
del eje geoeconómico que estaba en el
atlántico norte durante gran parte del
si no todo el siglo 20 hacia el
asia-pacífico
y ahora con lo de autos lo que tenemos
es que se manifiesta que ya no es sólo
el eje geoeconómico que se ha corrido
del atlántico norte hacia el
asia-pacífico ahora también es el eje
geopolítico en ese sentido yo creo que
francia lo tienes que tener presente
francés naturalmente tiene que tenía
históricamente una presencia en el
pacífico sur es algo que francia no
tiene que tener claro que ya el
atlántico norte no es el escenario
principal de la geopolítica mundial y va
a tener que me parece a mí que tener
tomar decisiones en ese plano y también
de acuerdo a esta noción de claro mía
estratégica claro es que francia tiene
de las colectividades de ultramar de
nueva caledonia y de la polinesia
francesa allí en la mitad del pacífico
tatiana para el cierre conclusiones 35
segundos yo creo que van a ver tomando
un poco lo que dice jorge conversaciones
entre francia y china yo creo que son
posibles y habrá que esperar la
estrategia que francia adopte pero
seguramente sí será conversar más con
homólogos en la región del indo pacífico
bueno pues a tatiana logon ya jorge
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate de france 24
yo aprovecho para recordarles que a
partir de el viernes 24 de septiembre
france24 en español pasó a transmitir 24
horas noticias netamente en español más
análisis más contexto más información y
también el debate este programa a partir
del lunes 27 pasa a ser transmitido de
lunes a jueves a las 7 y 20 horas
pasamos de una vez por semana a cuatro
veces a la semana gracias por habernos
acompañado gracias por la sintonía
[Música]